im ganzen land eigentlich erstaunlich in
einer liberalen demokratie aber der
liebgewonnene westlichen lebensstil
fährt derzeit bestenfalls mit
angezogener handbremse
die zahl derer denen die korona
beschränkungen ausgeschlagen scheint
zuzunehmen und jetzt auch noch eine
mögliche extrarunde lockdown wegen der
mutationen der geduldsfaden wird dünner
schnelltests impfen grenzen dicht was
hilft gegen die mutationen jetzt in der
phoenix runde
herzlich willkommen bei uns meine gäste
zunächst hier im studio
christina satori ist bei uns sie ist
freie wissenschaftsjournalistin kerstin
münstermann leitet das parlamentsbüro
der rheinischen post hier in berlin und
zugeschaltet ist der virologe und
epidemiologe professor klaus stöhr
sie waren früher koordinator des
globalen influenza programms der whu
also es ging beschäftigen sich also mit
grippeviren aller art und schließlich
ulrich reitz der ist chefkorrespondent
von focus online herr stöhr werden denn
uns die mutationen des corona virus noch
länger zu hause oder in der
unmittelbaren umgebung ihrer wohnung
festhalten auch die nächsten wochen noch
die anteilsmäßige zunahme der variante
weil in der erkrankungsfälle
gleichzeitig einhergeht mit abnehmender
inzidenz sind gesamteuropa gleichzeitig
in gips in der ganzen welt 17
prozentiger rückgang der inzidenz und
andere länder gehen die sache auch
anders an die machen viel eher auf
frankreich hat geschäfte und schulen
geöffnet in österreich auf ich glaube
wir sind so ein bisschen die letzten die
da wohl darüber nachdenken jetzt schnell
zu öffnen
foto ri reicht denn die jetzige corona
abwehr die wir haben in deutschland aus
zu bekämpfung der mutanten die uns hier
möglicherweise noch in größerer zahl
bevorstehen
also ich glaube diese locker und jetzt
der jetzt dass der auch noch verlängert
wird bis anfang märz ist sehr wichtig
man sieht ja auch dass wir nicht die
einzigen sind in europa die jetzt noch
einen starken locker und habe ich meine
england und irland sind haben gesagt bis
anfang märz bleiben wir im harten locker
und der ist härter als der in
deutschland als er möchte ich ein
bisschen widersprechen ich denke es ist
ganz wichtig dass man einmal diese
maßnahmen benutzt
vielleicht nicht alle auf einmal aber
die wir jetzt schon machen um die
mobilität der menschen einzuschränken
dann gleichzeitig wenn man über
lockerungen spricht ganz klar sagt es
muss mehr getestet werden um ganz
schnell neue fälle aufzudecken keine
großen ausbrüche zu erlauben oder zu
übersehen und das mit dem impfen muss
ganz schnell gehen
das ist wirklich ein wettrennen gegen
die zeit jetzt weil diese mutation
jedoch deutlich ansteckender ist die
verbreitet sich enorm das hat das robert
koch institut gestern noch mal
festgestellt und wir haben england und
irland und portugal gesehen wohin das
führt zu überfüllten krankenhäusern
diese ganzen anfänger und klappern wir
in der sendung ja noch einzeln tatra
münstermann die stimmung im land scheint
ja in einer richtung gerade zu kippen
erstmals sind nach einer umfrage mehr
menschen unzufrieden oder mehr sind
unzufrieden als zufrieden mit der
aktuellen corona politik ja frank walter
steinmeier der bundespräsident hat heute
von einem beginnenden vertrauensverlust
in die staatlichen oder in die
öffentlichen institutionen gesprochen
also auch er merkt dass als
staatsoberhaupt und ich glaube schon
dass für die nächsten wochen eine
politische legitimation für diese ganzen
maßnahmen wie sie ja vor allem angela
merkel immer verkörpert sehr viel
schwieriger wird aber sind der
bundeskanzlerin und den
ministerpräsidenten nicht auch die hände
gebunden
eine mutation sketche in die nur langsam
sinkenden oder vielleicht sogar
stagnierenden infektionszahlen und
incident ziehen
und wenn das passiert würde gegen das
ganze jahr von vorne los mit
möglicherweise einem noch härteren
lockdown als jetzt
er kenne sie können mich gerne
politische sachen freien alles was mit
ärzten zu tun hat und viren
da würde ich mich immer den experten
eher an vertrauen auf jeden fall ist es
so dass der druck auf die
bundesregierung erheblich steigt
galoppieren und geradezu steigt die
rechtfertigung des notwendigkeit nimmt
in einem hohen ausmaß zu was auch
damit zusammenhängt dass die
kommunikation oft genug unglücklich
gewesen ist sich widersprechende
botschaften ausgegeben wurden die
verunsicherung in der bevölkerung die
hat auch den grund dass eine reihe von
fehlern passiert sind und nach wie vor
passieren also die frage hat er durchaus
auch eine politische richtung gerade
aber professor stöhr hat uns ja gerade
etwas gesagt über den sachverhalt dass
zwar die dass die inzidenz ziehen also
dass die neuinfektionen sinken aber
gleichzeitig die mutanten die
ansteckende mutante größer wird und der
anteil an der gesamten kranken größe ein
interessanter aspekt wir gucken uns da
mal eine grafik an die uns professor
stöhr auch hat zukommen lassen und zwar
am beispiel von irland und das und vom
vereinigten königreich
hier sehen sie die beiden kurven die
kurve etwas weiter nach oben geht es die
irische die rote kurve ist die britische
und das war der der spitzenwert und dann
fiel diese kurve das ist die zahl der
neuinfektionen der incident ziehen pro
100000 einwohner in sieben tagen diese
berühmte zahl wieder stark ab und dann
sehen sie oben aber an den blauen balken
sowohl irland als auch im vereinigten
königreich ist die der anteil der
ansteckenden mutante gewaltig gestiegen
von 20 auf 50 prozent und in irland und
im vereinigten königreich von 50 auf 90
prozent das heißt die anstecken der
anteil der ansteckenden mutante steigt
und gleichzeitig sinkt die zahl der
infektionen herr stöhr woher kommt das
denn das ist ja eigentlich eine
gegenläufige entwicklung
man erwartet ja eigentlich das gegenteil
ja genau das ist ja das was wir nicht
nur inland und in england sehen wir
sehen das ja auch in anderen ländern
in frankreich wo die instanzen
gleichmäßig auf ungefähr 200 fahren
in der schweiz wo die leicht sinken delo
markt wo die fälle linear fallen und
auch überall dort nimmt die variante
anteilmäßig zu weil das passt überhaupt
nicht zu den befunden die in england im
dezember und sagen
januar erhoben wurden im labor und auch
durch epidemiologische befunde und es
gibt auch ein paar mythen die hier
existieren zum beispiel dass in holland
der anstieg durch die variante
verursacht war das ist überhaupt nicht
der fall also die schlussfolgerung für
mich kann nur sein dass man sich die
werte anschaut die modelle die
laborbefunde und sie gegenüber stellt
mit dem empirisch erhobenen daten in den
letzten wochen und hier eindeutig
feststellen muss dass der ausdruck höher
infektiös nicht kontrollierbar ich will
gar nicht in die anderen romantischen
leitungen für mich verfahren hineingehen
kann so eindeutig dass man auch dieses
virus beherrschen kann
ich glaube dass die
durchsetzungsfähigkeit ist wieder was
eindeutig höher ist das wird tatsächlich
die szene übernehmen von alle anderen
wären verdrängen
aber die höhere durchsetzungsfähigkeit
gegenüber einem anderen virus geht nicht
einher auf kundenfragen der empirischen
daten mit einem schwierig den höheren
schwierigkeiten bei der kontrolle de
france motorik können wir denn damit
rechnen in deutschland stehe erst am
anfang dieser mutations entwicklung
verglichen mit irland und dem
vereinigten königreich dass es bei uns
auch so glimpflich verläuft dass zwar
der anteil der mutation der ansteckenden
stu nimmt aber trotzdem die inzidenz und
runter gehen
naja ich denke das hängt von den
maßnahmen ab also wie ansteckend ein
virus es das ergibt sich einmal daraus
wie es biologisch aufgebaut ist also wie
gut es einfach von sich aus ungehemmt
sich verbreiten kann da ist ihnen sind
die neuen varianten ist besondere die
britische besser als das alte saß kopf
zwei dass wir aus dem letzten sommer
kennen es kann einfach mehr leute
anstecken man weiß noch nicht warum aber
man sieht ist und dementsprechend müssen
die maßnahmen noch stärker gemacht alte
stärke eingehalten werden ich möchte
noch mal betonen in irland und england
sind die zahlen gesunken weil man da
einen haken locker und gemacht hat man
kann nicht nur auf die zahlen gucken und
sagen die ist die verteilung der
mutation und dann bewerten wie hat sich
das insgesamt entwickelt die zahl der
inzidenz sondern man muss ja auch gucken
welche maßnahmen wurden ergriffen und in
dem moment wo alle zu hause bleiben und
alle schulen geschlossen werden und alle
panik haben weil in england die
krankenhäuser überfüllt sind und in
london
die krankenwagen vor den krankenhäusern
schlange stehen und jeder bleibt zu
hause
natürlich geht die inzidenz runter egal
was du eine mutante sie da haben aber
selbst in deutschland ist es dieser
lockt nicht so hat jetzt habe
ich heute irgendwo gelesen es gibt eine
prognose wir sind dabei 22
das hat der bundesminister für
gesundheit gestern verkündet also der
anteil der positiven corona tests davon
diese gefährliche muttern der etwa 22
just zum dritten märz wenn das nächste
mal dass bund länder treffen ist wegen
der wegen des lockouts oder mögliche
lockerungen könnte die schon bei 80
prozent liegen was würde denn das für
die politische bewertung
das lockt das der weiterführung und der
korona infektionen bedeuten
wir hätten alle ein problem so wie wir
hier sitzen natürlich aber die politik
hätte deshalb ein problem weil die
maßnahmen sind hier nur so gut wie die
bereitschaft der bevölkerung diese
mitzutragen und davon hat deutschland
ganz ganz lange profitiert und ich
glaube wir sind jetzt wieder an so einem
punkt null angekommen und die nächsten
zwei wochen wird ist weiteren druck
geben zu öffnen egal was die zahlen
sagen die wirtschaft steht dahinter der
einzelhandel das hotelgewerbe aber auch
die menschen die
wieder raus wollen und leute treffen
wollen das wetter wird besser und sollte
tatsächlich so sein dass alles wieder
ansteigt diese
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz zwischen
kanzlerin merkel und den regierungschefs
der länder zu verfolgen wird dann sehr
interessant ich halte es zurzeit fast
für nicht möglich noch mal einen
schärferen locker und den bürgern zu
verkaufen bereits was meinen sie wird
der lock down oder so gleiten und
entwicklung ja ganz kurz so herrschte ja
ja ich bin vielleicht noch eine kleine
politische beobachter ich glaube in zwei
wochen wird es auch sehr schwer sein den
menschen immer noch zu verkaufen
das ist die variante den unterschied
macht weiter bekämpfen wir werden in
allen anderen ländern weiter den abfall
so wir haben momentan leitungs problem
offenbar auch die bekämpfung zu herrn
steuer dann würde ich mal sagen nämlich
die frage noch mal auf an ulrich reitz
ich sage ist es am dritten märz jetzt
unabhängig von der frage wie es mit den
incidents hinaus sieht gerade wegen des
auch von kerstin münstermann gerade
beschriebenen drucks überhaupt noch
möglich den lockdown weiterzuführen oder
noch zu verschärfen oder rechnen sie er
tatsächlich mit einer lockerung
ich rechne schon deswegen mit einer
lockerung weil sich die stimmung in der
bevölkerung dramatisch geändert hat weil
wir immer mehr und immer näher den
landtagswahlen in rheinland pfalz und
baden württemberg kommen weil die
politik nicht immer nur miese schlechte
negative botschaften verkünden kann
sondern ist auch eine perspektive gibt
aus dem tunnel bisher hat die
bundesregierung sich geweigert einen
plan zu eröffnen oder einen plan zu
entwickeln was sie ja eigentlich
angekündigt hat er eine perspektive
entwickeln würde wie es den menschen
wieder besser gehen kann und solange das
passiert wird der druck in der
bevölkerung einfach weiter steigen das
was die grünen und die fdp immer
gefordert haben
nämlich einen transparenten
berechenbaren plan zu entwickeln was
auch durchaus möglich ist wie das
beispiel etwa in italien zeigt mit einer
krone ampel die den leuten ermöglicht
jetzt in rom draußen zu sitzen und
schinken zu essen und wein zu trinken
das sehen die leute nicht mehr ein wenn
sie hier in deutschland nur von dieser
tristesse umgeben sind
welchen sinn macht aber bereits ein
stufenplan wenn er nach ein oder zwei
wochen praktisch wieder zurückgenommen
werden muss falls das wenn die kurven
dann doch wieder exponentiell steigen
herr keller was ist sinnvoller einen
plan für die bevölkerung der aus fünf
oder sechs bestandteilen und parametern
besteht denn nicht nur die inzidenz
beinhaltet sondern auch die auslastung
der intensivbetten den graz der impfung
usw
der für alle nachvollziehbar ist oder
eine hinter verschlossenen türen statt
findende ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
mit der kanzlerin wo man den eindruck
haben muss fragen sie mal herr stöhr
dass die wissenschaftler deren meinungen
nicht erwünscht ist gar nicht erst
eingeladen werden der favorit das ist ja
auch ein vorwurf immer wieder gewesen
dass sich die ministerpräsidenten
besonders das kanzleramt nur auf eine
wissenschaftliche meinung da
konzentriert und die wahrnimmt ist eher
gerechtfertigt
ich halte das nicht für gerechtfertigt
ich verstehe die diskussion nicht ich
finde das unheimlich beruhigend dass und
ich glaube deswegen sind wir bisher
relativ gut durch die ganze party
gekommen dass unsere regierung auf die
leute hört die ahnung davon haben und
das ist ja nicht nur der eine oder der
andere da ist natürlich da sind die
leute dabei die sich sehr gut mit
coronaviren auskennen da sind aber auch
wissenschaftler von ganz anderen
fachbereichen auch dabei ich man die
bundesregierung hat auch auf die
leopoldina gehört das ist ein ganzer
jetzt hätte ich fast haufen gesagt das
ist eine ganze gruppe von
wissenschaftlern verschiedenster
fachbereiche der fachbereiche pädagogen
sozialwissenschaftler und und ich finde
das wird immer ein bisschen schwarz weiß
dargestellt dass mit dem langfristigen
plan ist eine schöne idee hat hier
bisher immer leider das virus uns einen
strich durch die rechnung gemacht weil
das ist biologie das kommt eigentlich
immer wieder so ein bisschen schlauer um
die ecke als wir sind und dann muss man
eben flexibel sein
was es ja gibt ist vielleicht nicht so
eine ampel inzwischen ich habe sie auch
nicht ausreden lassen
es gibt ja inzwischen schon lange diese
in tänzen an dem man sich orientiert es
wird außerdem auch auf die auslastung
der intensivbetten geguckt das ist ja
nicht so als wenn es da nicht ein
register gebe auch dass man täglich
gucken würde bereits jetzt also schwarz
weiß wird im kanzleramt gespielt
tatsächlich werden die eingeladen die
eine harte linie vertreten und natürlich
gibt es unter den wissenschaftlern auch
den virologen apple tpd millionen
anderer meinung
tatsächlich ist es ja so dass der
tschentscher der hamburger regierende
bürgermeister gerne mal gehabt hätte
dass herr stöhr in dieser runde im
kanzleramt teilnimmt das kanzleramt
wollte aber nicht auch herr strikt der
im team ist von armin laschet und in
seinem sinkt auch der ist bei der
kanzlerin nicht erwünscht bei der
leopoldina ist es so dass dort die zahl
derjenigen die eine die sozusagen sich
verschrieben haben einer neuen strategie
mit dem drücken einer inzidenz auf die
zahl 10
dass die deutlich in der mehrheit ist
verbringt man frau prise man usw
das heißt wir haben es damit zu tun
mittlerweile wird ja auch aus dem kreis
der leopoldina der vorwurf erhoben dass
die kanzlerin die wissenschaft sozusagen
in einer geiselhaft nimmt für ihre
politische position so was kostet
glaubwürdigkeit es spricht sich herum
und deswegen ist dass der wesentliche
grund deshalb die glaubwürdigkeit zahlen
für die regierung so herunter gegangen
sind keine verengung entschuldigung aber
auf die verengung auf diese person
merkel sie habe es ja gerade gesagt also
herr laschet hat andere virologen in
seinem team und der trägt diese
beschlüsse ja mit es ist ja mitnichten
so dass bei die ver
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz frau merkel
reihen gesagt sie hätte das gerne so und
danach gehen 16 ministerpräsidenten in
ihrer länder und ministerpräsidentinnen
und erklären was ihnen die kanzlerin
gesagt hat machen wir jetzt also die
diskussion wird dabei ja völlig
ausgeblendet was man frau merkel sicher
vorwerfen kann es ist schwierig wenn man
wochenlang
eine zahl unter 50 sie hatten die 50 sie
hat immer unter 50 gesagt gesprochen hat
und dann auf einmal bei 35 rauskommen
diese differenz ist schon relativ groß
die aber herr laschet ja mit beschlossen
hat zunächst mal der stör bitte ich
hoffe die ton deine läuft wieder
jetzt hab ich das ganze jahr bereits
momentan kleinen momente stöhr eine
bemerken auch eine bemerkung noch zu
diesem zu diesem krach um herrn laschet
er hat in wahrheit gesprochen über die
in dem er gesagt hat jetzt kommen immer
wieder neue werte um die ecke und werden
erfunden usw
er hat ja in wahrheit gesprochen über
diesen okotie zahl von zehn und nicht
über die von ihm gemeinsam mit
beschlossene zahl von 35 bei der
inzidenz gut das war jetzt eine
klarstellung
ja ich möchte dich von den disco dance
ablenken aber gerne dort mitmachen
alle die die glaube ich die politik wird
wo ich große schwierigkeiten haben in
den nächsten wochen zu herauszukommen
aus der diskussion wegen den varianten
oder mutanten wie die dann ein bisschen
dramatisch genannt werden müssen wir
jetzt die die maßnahmen verschärfen ich
gehe fest davon aus dass ihr der
bekämpfung deutschland weiter anhält
sich auch ein mythos dass in deutschland
eine stärkere lockerung gefahren wird
als in anderen ländern
das ist auch ein mythos zu glauben dass
die verschiedensten fachbereiche in
deutschland nicht an der diskussion
beteiligen es gibt dutzende von
fachverbänden deutsche gesellschaft für
pädiatrische infektiologie deutsche
gesellschaft für krankenhaushygiene
wir machen ja nicht pausenlos neue
stellungnahmen weil die sich gehört
gefühlen von der politik sondern bei die
in ihrer bei ihrem interesse sich an der
gesellschaftlichen diskussion
wissenschaftlichen diskussionen zu
beteiligen
das gefühl haben nicht gehört zu werden
also
ich glaube nicht dass man tatsächlich in
deutschland im wissenschaftlichen
diskurs fördert dass es eine plattform
gibt auf dem die kollegen ihre gedanken
schärfen können auf denen sie gemeinsam
und sicherste lösung bringen können im
vorfeld der politik entscheidung sondern
bei der risikoabschätzung es kann ja
nicht sein dass einzelne kollegen mit
ihrer einzelmeinung in einer diskussion
gehen wichtig und richtig so kann ich
das aus meiner beratung von regierung
wäre es im vorfeld von solchen
entscheidungen große gruppen von
kollegen zu problemen befragt zu
befahren und unterschiedlichste
meinungen zusammenzuführen alternativ
projekte oder alternativ lösung zu
entwickeln deren vor und nachteile zu
evaluieren und die stellt man dann der
politik vor
und das würde dann fiel das die breite
und auch die tiefen das will ab und ich
glaube wir kommen mit unserer
gegenwärtigen prozess der einbeziehung
der wissenschaft nicht so gut zurecht
wie das vielleicht in anderen ländern
ist sagt sie noch gleichen schweiz und
einer großen usa hat man ganz andere gut
wir haben nach wie vor etwas tun
probleme mit der leitung zerstören
hoffen dass das blatt wir wollen
probleme die hier gewählte jetzt gewählt
haben sind ja möglicherweise ganz kleine
probleme wenn eines gelingt was wir uns
alle hoffen nämlich das impfstoff in
ausreichender zahl kommen dass die
wirksam sind und dass die eine
ausbreitung des coaches 2 und der
mutationen verhindern
dazu gibt es ist allerdings eine neue
diskussion wieder aufgemacht worden ist
und darauf ist gestern der
bundesgesundheitsminister mit einer
kurzen äußerung hat bei seiner
pressekonferenz eingegangen dass wir uns
kurz anhören wenn wir ein bisschen
aufpassen dass wir uns da selbst nicht
auch als gesellschaft in was rein reden
und ein wirklich wirksames instrument in
dieser pandemie nämlich eine
schutzimpfung mit einem zugelassenen
sicheren und wirksamen impfstoff dann
irgendwie in frage stellen hersteller
diese äußerung bezog sich auf
astrazeneca und die die zweifel die da
geäußert worden sind in den letzten
tagen an der wirksamkeit was wie würden
sie das einschätzen diese diskussion und
auch diesen wirkstoff ist da ist
tatsächlich muss man tatsächlich etwas
bedenken
oder jammern wir auf allerhöchstem
niveau doch das greift das ja gut hier
vor einem halben jahr hätten wir uns
alle gefreut
ein impfstoff zu haben mit 70
prozentiger wirksamkeit
jetzt haben wir die glückstreffer
gelandet mit dem mba namen stoffen 94 95
prozentige wirksamkeit dass jetzt das
ziel natürlich sehr hoch
jetzt für die leute nicht gleich als
zweiter klasse behandelt weil sie mit
einem tollen team steinig games werden
können
das ist sehr politischen diskussionen
aus auch nicht schwierig für mich würde
der akademiker im stoff als jemand der
nichts oder hochrisikogruppe gehört
absolut in ordnung sein
natürlich sollte man die gesunden
erwachsenen die können sich damit impfen
lassen es ist ja auch nicht so dass man
jetzt glaubt wenn man eine infektion hat
dass die auch zu verhindern wäre also
alle dämmstoffe werden nicht
hundertprozentig schützen die geben
keine sterile immunität und die astra
und den ek impfstoff ist für alle die
ihm keine besonderen schwierigen
konditionen haben dass sie schwer krank
oder überhaupt 75 80 sind über 65
fröhlichkeit gut also es wird ja schon
zurückgerudert nach diesen vorwürfen
dass astrazeneca jetzt auch was
professor stöhr gesagt hat ja ein
wirksamer impfstoff ist sie haben gerade
vor satori von den schlauen viren
gesprochen manche menschen sind auch
schlau einige haben jetzt den vorschlag
gemacht man könne ja wenn man sich mit
astrazeneca geimpft hat dann zur
absicherung dass es wirklich wirksamer
schutz ist dann gleich mit diesen nr
impfstoffen also diesen gegen
gentechnisch hergestellten impfstoffen
von bayer pfizer nachimpfen lassen ist
das sinnvoll ist das eine gute
kombination das ist eine überlegung die
jetzt gemacht wird
von von den forschern einfach im
hinblick auf die tatsache dass sich zum
beispiel in südafrika und in brasilien
varianten verbreiten und zwar sehr
schnell verbreiten die wo es sein konnte
dass die impfstoffe nicht mehr so gut
funktionieren also hier in deutschland
sind diese mutanten ja noch nicht so
verbreitet das würde auch nicht heißen
dass die impfstoffe gar nicht mehr
wirken aber langfristig gesehen denken
die impfstoffhersteller halt kann sein
dass wir ihn im jahr ein anderes konzept
anbieten müssen und dann wäre das eine
möglichkeit dass man dann sagt gut sie
wurden jetzt schon zweimal gegen
durch astra zenica geimpft jetzt geben
wir noch einmal einen m rna impfstoff
drauf um die man vielleicht auch noch
mal angepasst hat um eben auch gegen
dieses was da jetzt neu aufgetreten ist
oder was vielleicht auch noch kommt dann
entsprechend eine gute wirkung zu haben
jetzt wenn der lange her dass diese in
rna impfstoffe von montech und von
moderner ungefähr 90 sogar mehr als 90
prozentige wirksamkeit haben und der von
astrazeneca nur 60 dann im moment also
irgendwie dann gibt es doch gewaltige
qualitäts und ja das wird aber auch
manchmal in der presse muss ich leider
sagen auch falsch dargestellt und die
sind ja so aufleben also es ist nicht so
dass man diese zahlen so miteinander
vergleichen kann wie zu sagen das ist
ein liter wasser und das sind anderthalb
liter wasser man kann die prozentangaben
aus den wirksamkeitsstudien die für die
zulassungsbehörden gemacht wurden nicht
direkt miteinander vergleichen
ob das eine jetzt 86 prozent sind und
dass andere 94 das ist diese studien
haben zum teil unterschiedliche
altersgruppen
die haben zum teil auch unterschiedliche
ziele der eine guckt drauf werden nur
schwere verläufe und todesfälle
verhindert der andere guckt werden
überhaupt symptome also auch husten
schnupfen heiserkeit verhindert das
heißt man kann nicht äpfel und birnen
miteinander vergleichen
dietz wassers fakt was der fakt ist die
drei wirkstoffe die jetzt zugelassen
sind in deutschland auch astra zenica
zeigen eine wirklich gute wirksamkeit
mann hatte am anfang so hofft man kriegt
60% wirksamkeit der sind die weit drüber
die sind gut verträglich das zeigen die
daten also wie hier stört schon sagte
vor ein paar monaten hätten wir das ist
echt ein luxusproblem dass wir was
einige leute jetzt ja auch mal ein paar
monaten hätten wir jubelt wenn wir den
gehabt hätten der ist gut der ist sicher
der schützt diese diskussion um
astrazeneca in den letzten tagen zeigt
die die ganze aufgeregtheit der
diskussion des streits der unsicherheit
auch der vielleicht auch schlechten
kommunikation das nicht dass man an
diesen impfstoff sozusagen abarbeitet
und jetzt ja sogar aus dem medizinischen
bereich personal geweigert hat geweigert
haben soll sich mit diesem impfstoff
impfen zu lassen
ja es ist komplett schädlich denn also
erst hieß es die briten impfen wie die
weltmeister mit was impfen die briten
mit astrazeneca
das konnte deutschland dem kann man
nicht hinterher und jetzt haben wir
impfdosen die ja fehlten im januar die
sind jetzt da und jetzt gibt es leere
impfzentren also ich glaube dieses diese
diskussion ist gefährlich und sie zeigt
wie ein brennglas aber an was es fehlt
also jetzt haben wir im zentren in allen
ländern die haben impfdosen
es gibt es einen teil der die dran sind
die wollen sich nicht impfen lassen und
was passiert nichts
also die idee dass man dann schnell
handelt und sagt wir haben das jetzt
übrig dann gehen wir schneller voran
dann fordern wir in unserer stadt die
und die aufkommt doch lasst euch impfen
also jeder der geimpft ist egal in
welcher im gruppe er sich befindet ist
ja für die gesellschaft 1 gewinnen und
ich glaube in dieser krise in der wir
oder in den punkt indem wir jetzt sind
sind es so diese schnellen pläne diese
ideen wie könnte es gehen also heute hat
in nordrhein westfalen das land begonnen
sich an einem konzertveranstalter zu
wenden
die nämlich erfahrungen damit haben was
passiert wenn ganz viele leute zur
selben zeit auf die server zugreifen um
diese impf vergabe besser zu machen also
die idee auch auf das schon vorhandene
wissen zurückzugreifen auch in der
wirtschaft bei konzernen wo auch immer
thema schulen dass man eigene software
entwickeln muss nur damit der
geschichtsunterricht der klasse 7b
sicher ist ich verstehe ich mich bereits
wie steht's denn eigentlich bei uns um
die oder wie ist es um die politische
aufklärung bestellt man erinnert sich ja
vor vielen jahren gab es eine kampagne
gegen aids und hiv es gib aids keine
chance ist dass damals auch andere
kampagnen gesundheitskampagnen wird
verglichen mit damals die wahrheit
offenbar sehr wirksam diese kampagne
wird verglichen mit damals von seiten
der politik in einer situation die ja
nicht nur gesundheitsschutz bedingt
sondern auch den schutz der wirtschaft
die stabilität der gesellschaft wird
heute von der politik zu wenig
aufgeklärt zu wenig informiert sie
können wir haben heute eine völlig
andere mediane und kommunikative
wirklichkeit also die vorstellung sie
könnten mit einer
vom bundespresseamt oder aus dem
kanzleramt oder vom
bundesgesundheitsminister gesteuerten
kampagne auch nur irgend etwas erreichen
wenn sie nachrichten dagegen haben dass
das medizinische personal in hohem maße
sich nicht mit astrazeneca impfstoff
impfen lassen will
das können sie gleich vergessen ich habe
eben unmittelbar vor der sendung noch
mal nachgeguckt und mir ist eine umfrage
die erste glaube ich diese art über die
impfbereitschaft sozusagen aufgefallen
die ist vom spiegel und in dieser
umfrage steht drin dass die
impfbereitschaft noch nie so hoch war
wie jetzt gerade nämlich 80 prozent was
er ein toller wert ist damals vor ein
paar wochen und monaten noch ganz andere
diskussionen gehabt 80 prozent in
bereitschaft eine tolle geschichte
dass aber die bereitschaft sich mit
astrazeneca impfen zu lassen
zwei bis drei prozent ist wohlgemerkt
bei denjenigen die sich impfen lassen
wollen
also das kind ist bereits in den brunnen
gefallen und es hat angefangen damit
dass die ständige impfkommission gesagt
hat dieser impfstoff der den empfehlen
wir nicht bei menschen die über 65 jahre
alt sind und dann kam die diskussion und
die ersten berichte über die
nebenwirkungen und da kann man
tausendmal der meinung sein dass auch
herr drosten gesagt hat und was sicher
richtig ist man kann tausendmal der
meinung sein dass die nebenwirkungen
sozusagen der der packungsbeilage
entsprechen
dieser meinung kann man sein und dennoch
ist es so dass einfach wenn viele
mediziner oder krankenschwestern oder
pflegekräfte sich weigern sich mit
diesem impfstoff impfen zu lassen
dann schafft das noch mal eine ganz
andere kommunikative wirklichkeiten ich
wäre dafür dass diejenigen die jetzt
sagen wir wollen uns mit astrazeneca
impfen lassen dies auch tun die frage
wäre ob es sinnvoll ist das nicht
prominente jetzt aus dem quark kommen
und sagen wir lassen uns damit impfen
wie etwa herr drosten oder auch karl
lauterbach
wer ein paar hundert tausend follower
auf twitter
das sind große beispiel und er will dass
in der nächsten woche tun in leverkusen
denn er auch anfangen will selber zu
verkämpfen das sind gute beispiele
mit einer kampagne der bundesregierung
glaube ich erreichen sie nicht besonders
viel
es gibt ja frau satori den vorschlag
einer großen deutschen zeitung mit
großen buchstaben heute dass sich die
bundeskanzlerin auch impfen lassen soll
ist das als vorbild charakter ist das
wäre das sinnvoll aus ihr das nicht ja
ich glaube so etwas zieht also wie sie
eben jetzt auch sagten dass das herr
lauterbach sich impfen lassen wird das
wird vielleicht viel überzeugen das ist
immer noch es ist zwar komisch weil da
sind dann ein zwei leute aber wenn
prominente das machen ich glaube es hat
eine große überzeugungskraft ich möchte
noch einmal nur damit das nicht falsch
verstanden der fall stehen bleibt
betonen dass die ständige impfkommission
gesagt hat wir machen es so wir sagen
dieser impfstoff wird erstmal nur an
leute unter 65 verimpft weil wir nicht
genügend daten haben das sind wirklich
nur zwei drei einzelne fälle die man hat
aus der höheren altersgruppe es wurde
nie gesagt er ist nicht gut für ältere
leute man erwartet sogar dass der auch
bei älteren menschen wird das wird jetzt
in den nächsten wochen und monaten
werden diese daten hoffentlich kommen
nur dass das nicht falsch hängen bleibt
herr stöhr war das ein fehler förster
sowie wenn sie keine empfehlung haben
wenn sie keine empfehlung aussprechen
vertrauen im stoff an über 65 jährige zu
fall impfen dann kostet sagt vertrauen
das ist doch klar und sie sehen doch wie
die leute darauf bin ich anders ist die
aus dem leisen medizinischen dass es
selbst aus dem ich als christ egal wie
sie das sehen die leute reagieren in der
medizin da drauf wenn selbst mediziner
sagen wir nehmen nicht diesen impfstoff
da kann man noch nicht dran vorbei
sondern hat das sind zwei verschiedene
sachen erstmal glaube ich gar nicht dass
das so viel medizinisches personal ist
wie sie sagen das sind ja es ist auch
eine allgemeinbevölkerung er dieser
unwille gegen astra zenica und ich
glaube das wird echt von einigen medien
einfach auch hoch gepusht damit sie
wieder ein thema haben und dann die
ständige impfkommission das schafft doch
vertrauen wenn die sagen der ist sicher
für alle wir haben genug daten für alle
unter 65 drüber haben wir einfach zu
wenig daten da sagen wir wir lassen es
erstmal das schafft doch vertrauen
vorher war die ganze zeit die diskussion
das geht so schnell dass wird nicht
anständig geprüft und
es wurde gesagt was wir anständig prüfen
können mit unserem gewissen mit unseren
regeln vereinbaren können ist für leute
unter 65 alles andere warten wir ab die
daten kommen noch das schafft das
schafft doch vertrauen und deutschland
ist nicht das einzige land ich glaube
italien und noch ein zwei andere länder
haben ähnlich reagiert wobei jetzt sagen
es gibt aber auch länder wie die schweiz
und glaube ich großbritannien wo
tatsächlich astrazeneca für alle
altersgruppen zugelassen sind also ist
nicht nur ein so mit dem blick auf die
uhr weil wir ja noch zwei andere themen
haben würde ich gerne zum nächsten thema
kommen das natürlich auch sehr wichtig
ist und in diesem zusammenhang oder für
dieses thema als einleitung haben dabei
sie einen fünften gast nämlich dem
bundesinnenminister und der hat heute an
der sächsisch tschechischen grenze
folgendes gesagt ich möchte noch
hinzufügen dass es auch außerordentlich
schwer wäre in deutschland vielen
bevölkerungsgruppen seit wochen große
große einschränkungen zuzumuten und
diesen menschen dann zu erklären ihr
müsst diese einschränkungen hinnehmen
aber einen gefährlichen virus lassen wir
ohne weitere kontrolle zu uns ins land
das kann niemand gegenüber der
bevölkerung glaubwürdig vertreten
hersteller für unsere entscheidung also
die deutsche entscheidung die grenzen zu
schliessen nach tirol nach tschechien
gibt es harsche kritik aus diesen
ländern auch aus anderen ländern von der
eu kommission hat deutschland denn keine
andere möglichkeit die mutation den
einsatz der mutation zu bekämpfen als
solche steuer grenzschließungen die ja
möglicherweise auch probleme mit für die
lieferketten mit sich bringen für
fabriken für handelsunternehmen auch für
viele arbeitnehmer die hier in wichtigen
berufen arbeiten und aus diesen ländern
kommen also der gedankliche ansatz ist
ja erst mal richtig ihr können wir hohe
incident niedrige wir müssen das
unternehmen wissen die es gibt und
spruch ja heißt die menschen da haben
nur ein satz der geschichte gelernt
nämlich dass man nichts aus der
geschichte gehabt dann
vor einem jahr waren wir in der
situation dass die usa in der weltweiten
verbreitung man hat wird trotzdem in
europa die grenzen hochgezogen hat
geglaubt dass man damit die schleppleine
positivos verhindern
wir haben auch jetzt die variante in
deutschland über 20 prozent in sascha
auch so wenn jetzt das mutanten gebet
also meines erachtens der gedanklichen
ansatz schon völlig unsinnig für mich zu
glauben dass man mit grenzschließung die
einstellung eines virus verhalten
verhindern kann dass schon bei uns ist
das anderes natürliche politische aspekt
aber den kann ich schon schlechter
einschätzen aber vom epidemiologischen
bekämpfung macht überhaupt keinen sinn
er wurde können wir nach den politischen
aspekt gleich von anfang münstermann war
das eine richtige entscheidung des
bundesinnenministers zusagen an diesen
weiten grenzen wo ja vor allem die
inzidenz zahlen sehr hoch sind nämlich
in tschechien und in tirol und die
zumindest in tirol sind die geschäfte
auch wieder aufgemacht werden trotz
dieser hohen inzidenz ian zu sagen also
wenn diese länder nicht einsehen dass
sie den corona virus das corona wir uns
anders bekämpfen müssen dann machen wir
jetzt vorübergehend die quellen sind ja
nicht dicht aber es gibt scharfe
kontrollen und etwa die hälfte der
grenzgänger wird ja zurückgewiesen
sie haben es gesagt das ist eine
symbolische entscheidung und in meiner
betrachtung kommt so etwas zu spät denn
dass diese institute sind sich zu
unterscheiden an der grenze das ist ja
schon länger klar
auf der anderen seite muss man natürlich
schon sagen dass es auch dem druck
geschuldet denen auch eine
öffentlichkeit aufbaut
also wenn man in diesem land so hohe
zahlen hat und man weiß in sachsen sind
die die pflegekräfte auch die ärzte zum
großen teil kommen aus tschechien und
diese problematik dass man grenzen
schließt und diese menschen dann nicht
mehr rein lässt das war allen die ganze
zeit bewusst und so lange die
deutschland die eu ratspräsidentschaft
inne hatte waren die grenzen offen also
ich glaube es ist eine mischung aus
einer gewissen verzweiflung und dem
dringenden wunsch aber auch zu zeigen
wir tun was also es ist halt nicht nur
ihr die keinen mehr treffen durfte
sondern wir kontrollieren hat unseren
grenzen und versuchen es draußen zu
halten dass das nicht funktioniert haben
wir alle gesehen
bereits sind diese grenzschließungen
gerechtfertigte zumindest das
gegenwärtig gibt es einen interessanten
aspekt nach dem ja tirol wieder ein hot
spot wurde in den letzten wochen
hat man ja sogar innerhalb österreichs
nicht mehr richtig reisen dürfen auch
die anderen bundesländern österreich
haben ja einreiseverbot für bürger aus
tirol erlassen als mindestens wollten
sie die einreise strikt kontrollieren
jetzt macht deutschland im prinzip das
gleiche mit den bayrischen ohne grenzen
ist das nicht gerechtfertigt was
seehofer da verkündet hat also es hat
mehr mit symbolpolitik und einer
gewissen panik zu tun wir haben übrigens
diese regionalen unterschiede je nach
incident ziehen die haben wir genauso in
italien also da können sie das auch da
können sie das auch beobachten und
italien waren dass man was am meisten
gebäude war wenn ich eins sagen darf
wissen sie ich komme aus nordrhein
westfalen und den nordrhein westfalen
hat diese landesregierung von anfang an
gesagt wir wollen die grenzen zu belgien
und zu den niederlanden auf keinen fall
schließen was haben sie gemacht
sie haben vor einem jahr eine
grenzüberschreitende neudeutsch task
force eingerichtet mit experten
staatssekretären minister diplomaten
aber auch wissenschaftlern und
logistikern die regelmäßig tagen die
eine standleitung haben und sich über
das virus aufkommen austauschen
grenzüberschreitend das hat dazu geführt
dass nordrhein westfalen weder vor einem
jahr noch heute in der gefahr steht die
grenzen zu seinen nachbarländern
schließen zu müssen wir haben millionen
von pendlern und die grenzen bleiben
offen und ich muss ich ehrlich sein das
ist für mich ein zeichen wie man durch
nachdenken und durch beherzte
grenzüberschreitende initiativen dazu
kommen kann eben eine grenze offen zu
lassen
das ist europäisch gewesen das muss ich
schon sein
jetzt drei dafür gesprochen haben die
grenzen offen zu lassen
ich muss sagen also innerhalb von
deutschland wird jeder aufgefordert seit
wochen nicht unnötige reisen zu machen
bitte zu hause zu bleiben bitte nicht zu
der verwandtschaft zu fahren weihnachten
nicht zu den eltern
zu fahren alle sollen so wenig wie
möglich mobil sein arbeiten sie mit dem
home office wenn es irgendwie möglich
ist weil inzwischen klar festgestellt
wurde
es gibt einen zusammenhang zwischen der
anzahl der infektionen und der mobilität
und wenn die grenzen zu sind oder die
sind ja nicht zu wenn er ordentlich
getestet wird und deswegen vielleicht
ein stau da ist dann dann grenzt das
auch die mobilität ein also wenn er
weniger tourismus möglich ist und so was
von daher finde ich ist es eigentlich
nur eine fortsetzung dessen was man
sowieso sagt bitte versucht so wenig wie
möglich mobil zu sein wenn man
grundsätzlich fragt wir wollen die
illegale einwanderung von viren ganz
besonders der mutation verhindern ist in
aussicht also aus sicht des
gesundheitsschutzes eine grenzschließung
eine sinnvolle maßnahmen verhindern kann
man das nicht das zeigen studien
verhindern können sie das nie durch
grenzschließung aber man kann zeit
gewinnen und ich muss sagen zeit ist
immer noch ganz ganz wichtig bei uns
jede woche die wir weiter diese mutation
weiter zurückhalten können lässt uns
zeit gewinnen menschen zu impfen und
dadurch weniger empfänglich zu machen
von daher vielleicht verschafft es uns
allen dass tatsächlich die varianten
eine höhere infektion sieht haben die
wir nicht beherrschen können die
variante haben eine höhere
durchsetzungsfähigkeit gegenüber andere
varianten die jetzt zirkulieren aber sie
haben keine offensichtlich höhere
infektion itt ansonsten könnte man die
bekämpfung nicht so gut durchführen und
noch mal klar zu sagen die bekämpfung
mitbürger in england im vergleich zu
deutschland ist wieder härter noch
weniger haben
doch der apple jünger und irland der
lock down in england und irland ist
härter als in deutschland da dürfen sie
am tag nur eine stunde dann kann man es
gleich mal anschauen da gibt
positionen die in allen ländern der welt
100 indizes sich anschaut die haben eine
karte entwickelt sie täglich erneuert
wird und die vergleichen die länder und
da deutschland die bekämpfung 684 und
england hat sie bekämpfen 683 liege in
größen von nur gesunde wenn sie uns so
stürmer kurz die karte ist jetzt eins
blendet kurz ansehen also sehen die ihr
dunkler das blau umso stärker ist eben
auch die einschränkungen sind die
maßnahmen also deutschland auch schon
relativ dunkel tschechien zb etwas
heller ganz hell schon im grünen bereich
das ist belarus wo das offenbar
überhaupt nicht stattfindet und in der
tat auf den inseln also vereinigtes
königreich und irland besonders tiefblau
wir haben nur noch wenige minuten
deswegen würde ich noch das thema
schnelltests gerne unter ihnen vier
brüderlich und schwesterlich aufteilen
münstermann der
bundesgesundheitsminister hat
angekündigt am ersten märz gibt es diese
schnelltests man geht dann die
bundeswehr die der bund also der staat
bezahlt dass man geht ein testzentrum
apotheke und dann kann man testen kann
man sich schon vorstellen was am ersten
märz das ist ein montag passiert machen
wir den gleichen fehler wie bei dem
versprechen was organisation verteilung
schnelligkeit angeht ich glaube
deutschland hat wirklich logistische
probleme und deswegen ist tatsächlich
die idee dass dann vor oder in apotheken
potenziell infizierte ganz nah
beieinander stehen um zu warten dass man
sich testen lassen kann ja doch absurd
also diese schnelltest bringen was ein
altenheim an schulen in kitas in
krankenhäusern klar aber die idee das
ist zwar nett dass jeder das jetzt kann
aber ob das wirklich hilft glaube ich
nicht bereits was glauben sie ist das
sinnvoll oder dritte das gut über die
bühne gehen
na ja wir haben ja beispiele dafür
wo ist wirklich geholfen hat das
berühmteste ist der sogenannte tübinger
modell von den grünen
oberbürgermeister palmer der es
geschafft hat damit die ausbreitung über
die sterblichkeit in seinen alten und
pflegeheimen deutlich zu senken
ich glaube wir reden hier von einem
sogenannten game changer also einem
einer geschichte die schon eine
veränderung des gesamten geschehens
bewirken kann
ich glaube vor allen dingen dass wenn
diese schnelltests für jedermann da sind
dass wir dann eine ganz andere zahlen
dichter haben eine ganz andere
möglichkeit die infektionsketten
unterbrechen zu können was ich mir
allerdings gewünscht hätte also muss ich
auch sagen also bevor man entscheidet
wir machen die schulen auf und dann
festlegt wie viel schnelltests man macht
hätte ich mir erst mal gewünscht man
macht ein konzept für die schnelltests
an schulen und dann die schulen auf gut
dann ist das die falsche reihenfolge
gewesen er stört erst die steigerung von
schnelltest ist ja eigentlich jeder darf
jetzt doktorspielen darf sich diese
bestecke sollen demnächst auch in den
hand gekommen ist das eine sinnvolle
ergänzung gerade wenn man keinen termin
bekommt dass diejenigen die vielleicht
auch häufig sich testen müssen dann
selbst testen um auch nicht so viel zeit
in testzentren zu verlieren also die
alle anderen maßnahmen der kontakt soll
es hier um das natürlich bleiben
hoffentlich bald gelockert werden und
die tests sind ja ein blick flaschen
damals noch mal was für mich wichtig
wäre klar zu sagen was kannst du dir
dann leisten wenn du deine test gemacht
hast geheimes lager muss geht das zu
bekämpfen in dem rest der populationen
muss man sagen okay lass dich testen um
die infekte nachfolgen aber was darüber
hinaus der das positive oder negative
testergebnis bietet an freiheit das muss
erstmal klar definieren werden war ich
dann lieber nichts zu auf den tee
gemischt s-klasse und dann vor ort kann
ich dann ins restaurant gehen kann ich
dann in den
die kann ich den stock gehen was ist
damit geplant mit ihrem negativen
ergebnis dann beginnt geregelt überlegen
diskussion wenn jemand jetzt positiv
geht er sich selbst testet müsste er ja
dann zumindestens auch sich dann melden
dass er mit der app schon nicht
besonders gut geklappt ist das ein
problem beim eigenen test wenn man kann
nur hoffen dass das dann die menschen
sich sich wirklich auch melden damit
eben dann kontakt könnten nachverfolgt
werden können
es wird ja auch gesagt da die schnell
jetzt doch eine größere fehlerquote
haben als einen pcr-test wenn jemand
positiv getestet ist sollte auf jeden
fall noch ein pcr test gemacht werden
das ist ja auch im interesse des
jeweilig jeweils der person weil
vielleicht ist das ja ein falsch
positives ergebnis und außerdem wenn ich
den test machen um meine eltern zu
besuchen dann will ich ja auch dass der
stimmt das heißt man musste mit ich
glaube daher steuerrecht das ist ganz
wichtig dass klar als was können diese
tests wie viel sicherheit geben die mir
wirklich in wievielen nicht und
natürlich auch das alles etwas nach
bestückt mit heißer nadel das war's für
diese sendung ich bedanke mich bei klaus
stöhr entschuldigung auch für den
schlechten ton wir hier zumindest uns
angekommen ist die zuschauer bei ulrich
reitz bei christina satori und bei
kerstin münstermann liebe zuschauer
jetzt folgt phoenix der tag mit michael
krons und wir kehren dahin zurück wo wir
vor der phoenix runde waren nämlich auf
den mars bleiben sie bei uns
[Musik]